Hello, everybody.
My name is Ellis Hughes.
And as you can tell, probably
from this title slide here,
I work at GSK.
I'm a data science leader in
the statistical data sciences
and innovation hub, same as
Becca, who presented earlier.
And we're responsible for
innovation and developing
of R packages to try to
improve processes and whatnot.
So I thought I'd come
here today to talk
about that a little bit.
So I think sorry.
I think we've all
worked on a process
before that promised the
world that it was supposed
to solve all our problems, make
our lives just substantially
easier.
And it didn't do that.
In fact, it made it harder.
It made it tougher.
Made it slower.
You were confused
the entire time.
And I call those Edsels.
Do you know what an Edsel is?
The Edsel is the automotive
world's biggest flop.
So I'm going to tell
you a little bit
of a story about the Edsel.
So in 1957, Ford is
hinting about the next car
that they're going
to be producing,
the car of the future
it's gonna be. They've
spent 10 years developing
this thing, $250
million of 1950s money,
which is $2.5 billion today.
And it's supposed to be this
fantastical thing that's
going to take us
all into the future,
and it's going to be full
of technologies that are
going to make our lives easier.
In 1958, the Edsel arrives
with a lot of fanfare.
They've got
advertisements all over
the world are all
over the states.
They've got a TV show
about the Edsel, a TV show
about the Edsel, of all things.
And it's got all this
wonderful technology.
Like in your steering wheel,
you can select your gear.
You don't have to gear shift.
It's just in your steering wheel,
it's right there for you.
On the dashboard,
there's a button
that squirts oil on
your front suspension
to keep it from squeaking.
Isn't that amazing?
But in 1959, they kill it.
It's done.
It's no longer
out there anymore.
In 1960, the last Edsel
rolls off the line.
This is a screen capture
from a Times Magazine
with the wrong car in the
wrong place at the wrong time.
But what happened
from 1957, where
it's the car of the
future, it's supposed
to be doing everything
for us, to 1959
it's dead.
It's gone.
Stop asking about it.
Well, there are a couple
of different problems
with the Edsel.
First, Edsel was
designed by committee.
There was no real why driving
the development of the Edsel
other than it's the
car of the future.
It's got to have everything.
It's going to be fantastic.
During this time,
also, Ford was going
through some restructuring,
some changing.
And so a lot of
different executives
were in charge of this
project over the 10 years
it was being
developed, of course.
So they all wanted to put
their thumbprint on the Edsel
to enable to push
their careers forward
without really paying respect
to what is this supposed to be?
What are we trying to
actually accomplish here?
And then, as I alluded
to earlier, 10 years
of development.
So when it was first released,
they were all in on this.
There were 18
different models that
were available for
people, not including
colors, internal trims,
all those other things.
This was just all
the models that
were available for the Edsel.
Then going on the idea that
there was no real why behind it,
there were no real
requirements or constraints
when they were designing it.
So the car design, the horseshoe
that you saw at the front,
there was thought
to be really ugly.
And in fact, people didn't
like the way that it looked.
Now, I don't really think it
looks too bad, but, you know,
whatever.
And then there also had
a bunch of technology
that didn't really
solve any problems
for us. It was technological,
technological solutions that
were searching for a problem.
They were trying to
identify that. You know
those automatic gearshift
selector in the steering wheel?
People hated it.
You know what you're used to
in the center of your steering
wheel?
A horn.
They'd hit the horn
and they'd actually
accidentally change gears.
In addition, there was a
lot of QA and QC issues
related to all those
technological solutions.
They weren't really
meant to be in production
that early, and that led
to issues where they were
the factory was
sending incomplete cars
to their dealerships with
just all the different pieces
that they didn't
complete just sitting
in the boot waiting for the
dealerships to sort this out.
And so that's why, of many
other reasons, the Edsel failed.
But how can we take
lessons from this
and keep our next project
from becoming the next Edsel?
So I'm going to go through a
little case study of a project
that we worked on where we
identified a slow process
that we wanted to fix.
So inside of our
organization, we
have a programming team
that does all our data
analysis and data prep.
They processes this data.
They do all this
formatting and they
output to several
different files
and intending for
downstream users
to use this to generate reports
and presentations and reports
and whatnot.
These downstream
users take this,
the statisticians will generate
reports or presentations,
and our medical
writers will generate
reports of differing levels
of programming backgrounds
and whatnot.
The issue with this
is our programmers
are generating data
in formats that
our downstream users
couldn't use directly.
That meant that there was a lot
of manual reproducing of data,
a lot of copy and
paste from the format
that we were producing
into their PowerPoint
and Word documents.
When people are
copying and pasting,
that leads to formatting
inconsistencies like, oh, I'll
just delete that.
I don't, I don't like
the way that looks.
I'll just put it
at the top there.
Or I want more spacing here.
I want to merge
these columns, not
fundamentally changing the data,
but the way it's displayed.
And because we're
doing all this copying,
pasting and
reformatting, we have
to do a lot of really intense QC
on data we've already generated
and already QCed to make sure
that we're not showing anything
that's incorrect.
So there's all this effort
going into this process that
is just we're not
producing the correct data,
we're not working, we're
not talking together
to make sure that everything
works together nicely.
But we saw this
as you know what?
That's not a bad thing.
That's an opportunity for us
to step in and help and try
to improve the process.
Because the data is being used
by the same downstream
user, the same data
are being used by
the downstream users,
we can use this as
a starting point,
and try to build processes
and build a package
to try to make
their lives easier.
Next, we found out and
learned about packages
that had come out like
the officeverse, which
is a series of packages by David
Gohel that interact with Office
products and help you write your
own XML to allow you to inject
and work with your
Word and PowerPoint
package or presentations
and documents and whatnot.
So officer. And there's
also flextable,
which is a package that
helps you make tables
into PowerPoints
and Word documents.
Kind of seems like it'll
be pretty useful for us.
So before we really went
and just went all full tilt
to develop anything, we
wanted to make sure we
had a full set of expectations
so we understood what
we were trying to build
before we went to go build it.
So if we're designing
a new workflow,
we want to create collaboration.
That that was what
was causing problems
before between our
programmers, statisticians
and medical writers.
We want it to work with
our existing systems.
We don't want to have to
try to create and roll up
a new system.
What do we have that?
What can we reuse?
Where can we extract
the data from?
How can we pull from
existing streams?
We're already using
PowerPoint and docx,
so let's output to that.
Let's not make our end
users relearn everything.
And then as we
generate these inputs,
let's automatically
tag those because you
can use comments in
PowerPoint and docx,
tag those with
comments that, hey,
you're going to
need to QC this.
This was generated custom.
And then ultimately this process
originally was very slow.
We want to reduce the timeline
into less than a week.
Then as we went to
go develop the team,
now that we had
our expectations,
we had a team, a very small
team of experienced individuals
that were both understood the
process, what they were trying
to replace, as well as
understood what they were
generating or how to program.
This is important.
So we understood what
were the constraints,
what could we feasibly
make or not make?
We had a single
point decision maker.
They were ultimately
responsible for making a call
if there was a
disagreement. Then
we worked with the experts,
the people that we're using,
our downstream users, as
well as upstream users
to define what are the core
things that we need to create,
what are the features that
need to be on the roadmap
eventually? we maybe don't
need them immediately,
but ultimately they did not
have the final decision.
They weren't the executives
at Ford that were telling us
what to do.
They were saying, hey,
it'd be really nice if.
We tried to simplify things.
We didn't want to try
to recreate the wheel.
Like I said, we didn't
want to recreate systems.
So let's use existing tools.
Let's use officeverse rather
than trying to make our home
cooked version of
officeverse to interact
with the XML and PowerPoint
and docx.
And let's use the tools
that already exist
and try to maybe improve
it as we need to.
People were adding their own
standards in their own changes
to the outputs.
So let's revert back to
what are the standards?
What exactly is it
that we have to make?
And then we can maybe
iterate from there.
And then identify areas of
common rework by the staff.
What are the common
reformatting that is being done
and can we do this
programmatically?
Is it reasonable to do
it programmatically?
What are things that we need
to capitalize or lowercase
or change?
While we develop this too,
we wanted to watch our scope.
So we wanted to make sure that
the system could grow as we
needed, to change as we needed.
The world is a changing place.
Let's try to keep that in mind.
The feature requests
that we got,
we would compare them against
the feasibility of doing that.
Once again, can we do
this programmatically?
Should we be doing
Or should we push back and go,
maybe this isn't the time.
We also have limited resources.
We have a small team of
people working on this.
So that made us keep in mind
that everything that we did
was in strict
adherence to the goals.
What are we actually
trying to achieve
and try to push away things?
This might sound a
little bit familiar.
This is kind of agile.
I don't know if you've
ever heard of that.
That's pretty popular.
So I'm happy to report that
this actually this project did
turn out pretty well.
We've reduced the reporting
time significantly,
things we've been able
to generate reports
in under a week.
There's no programming skills
required by our non programming
staff.
They are not required to
write any programming.
We're able to generate their
reports using the programmers
and then just running it through
this tool that we created.
And as everyone
asks in pharma, it
is validated per our
internal process.
So the reason this
project succeeded,
I believe it named a
couple of those as well.
We established our requirements.
We knew what our
outputs were, we
knew what we were
trying to create.
And we didn't deviate from that.
We knew what our
measurement of success was.
We knew if we achieved
this goal, we succeeded.
And anything that
we did was only
in trying to achieve that goal.
We were relentless. When people
asked us to do new
features, add new features,
we'd go, OK, do you
need this now or is
this something can happen later?
We kept perspective of the
values that we were adding
and tried, once again,
it's all about not
doing things we
don't need to do.
Don't add unnecessary
things unless you need to.
And then also single
point decision making.
Ultimately, one person
had to make a call.
OK I'm going to close
with a final story
from the same company, Ford.
And we're going to make
a GT, not an Edsel.
So 1966, Ford wins the
world renowned hardest race
in the racing world,
the 24 Hours of Le Mans, which
is a race where people drive
for 24 hours and the
winner is determined
not by how many laps they
do, but how far they drive.
This is a true endurance test
of the quality of your car.
How good is it made?
How well did you design this?
The impressive thing
about this, Ford,
this is the second year Ford
had ever competed in Le Mans.
They'd never competed in
an competed in it before.
The prior winner
had been Ferrari,
who'd won for the
last six years and has
a long history in racing.
So how did Ford go
from a company that
made a thing like the Edsel
to the GT and won
the whole darn thing
in their second
year of competing?
Well, they had a
small, dedicated team.
They set out to beat Ferrari.
That was their goal in mind,
not just win for the 24 hours
of Le Mans, but
let's beat Ferrari.
They get they got together a
small team of Carroll Shelby
and Ken Miles, who had
a history of success
doing this sort of thing.
Carroll Shelby was an old
racer, so he used to race.
He actually won Le Mans
I think a decade or two before
and started his own car company
called Shelby American.
You might know him
from the Shelby Cobra.
As well as Ken
Miles, who had been
a successful driver in
Britain, racing various cars
of various degrees.
And then everything they
did for the next two years
was focused on results.
What could they do to
make the GT faster?
How could they win Le Mans?
They worked
through aerodynamics.
They had an initial concept.
They did.
They constantly drove around.
They had the drivers that
were going to be in the race
drive the car around, give
feedback to the engineers.
Even this is a picture of
the engineers and drivers
with little pieces of string
that they taped onto the GT
to see how aerodynamics
worked and if there
were any areas of low
pressure that they
would need to address.
And they trusted the
drivers experience.
In addition to that, they
pushed technologies forward.
They took the Ford's proven
racing engine from NASCAR
and improved it.
They made it faster,
they made it stronger.
They took existing technologies
and made it better.
And they also innovated.
They took the quick change or
they invented the quick change
brake pads and rotors.
The GT was a very heavy car.
They break a lot
in Le Mans or they
have to press the brake pad.
So they needed a
quick way to redo this.
So they created new
technologies in order
to solve the problems
at hand, and that was
all they were ever focused on.
How can we do this faster?
How can we do this better?
So I'm going to end
with this. Projects
and packages should be
designed with purpose
and be relentless in
pursuing their goals.
That's how you make a
good package and process.
Thank you.